THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY MY NAME IS SABRINA SAID
ABOUT THIS AND I SERVICE THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE WE ARE
ALSO JOINED BY TONY SIMONS OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT OF THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE. AS
WELL AS JENNA GILLEN CONSULTANT
WITH THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
POLICY UNIT. JOINING US FROM
THE COMMITTEE OFFICE IS JODY
DEVISED THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY
FOR THE SOMEBODY JOBS COMMITTEE.
IF THERE ARE ANY TECHNICAL
ISSUES WITH THE CONFERENCE LINE
JODY IS AVAILABLE TO ASSIST YOU
SHE CAN BE REACHED AT
916-319-2090 JUST QUICKLY WANT
TO GO OVER THE SCHEDULE TODAY
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS TWO BILLS
INCLUDING ITEM ONE. SB SIX TWO
FIVE FIVE SENATORS W. HAT- AND
THE MINE. HAD DIED THIS BILL
ACTUALLY HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHORS. TODAY WE WILL BE
HEARING ITEM TWO SB SIX EIGHT
FOUR BY SENATOR WEST SO
RELATING TO THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER COMMISSION. AND ITEM
THREE SB EIGHT OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR ROTH RELATING TO THE
MADE IN CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. ARE
THERE ARE NO BILLS ON CONSENT
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS I LET ME DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE LIST OF
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WHICH YOU EACH HAVE
A COPY AT YOUR DESK. BEFORE WE
DO BEGIN OUR BILL PRESENTATION
I DO NEED TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF HOW THE PUBLIC WILL
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING I DO TO COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN PERSON. WE ALSO
ARE REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN
BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITES IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASS
WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. BUT
WE DO HAVE A FEW OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY FOR THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM. FOUR THREE
SEVEN IT ANYONE IS USING THAT
ROCK OPTION. IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFYING TO BILL
PEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM PEOPLE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT MAY USE THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS. THESE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HERE HEARING
ROOM ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS.
FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES THERE
WILL BE A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC CAN
TESTIFY IN THE BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU WERE CALLING AND
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE BILL
PRESENTATION. AND THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. I DO WANT
TO REMIND THOSE HER CALLING IN
TO PLEASE A WOMAN NAY ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST. OF YOUR SMARTPHONE
DEVICES REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COOPERATION AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. SO LET ME
GO AHEAD AND START. WITH THE
SUBMACHINE A QUORUM WELL THEY
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SO WE CAN FORMALLY
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. YOUR
CERVANTES HERE CARE CERVANTES
HERE FASTER CUNNINGHAM. SUMMER
BOERNER HORVATH HERE IS A
MEMBER- HARBACH HERE SOMETHING
RICH HOUSE. SELLING MEMBER
CHILD CARE SUMMER
PETRIE-NORRIS. HOWEVER AFTER
THE SEVEN MEMBER RAMOS. HELLO
RAMOS HERE SOMETHING MEMBERS
MET. SO IMMERSED. MADAM YOU
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU MEMBERS
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
MEMBER NOW READY TO BEGIN A
REGULAR ORDER BUSINESS AS I
NOTED EARLIER ITEM ONE SB SIX
TWO FIVE BY SENATOR COUPLE YET
ONLY MON I RELATING TO
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM THE HEARING AGENDA. TODAY
WE ARE HEARING SB SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR WEST SO RELATING TO THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER COMMISSION A
BEFORE THE AUTHOR DOES BEGAN
HIS BILL PRESENTATION LET ME
GIVE EVERYONE NOTICED THAT THE
PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
WITNESSES TO GET IN THE QUEUE
SENATOR WEST SO. I UNDERSTAND
YOU WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED
GOT A COMMENT EIGHT OF THE BILL
ANALYSIS YES MANAGER. THANK YOU
I MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL ADOPT THESE AMENDMENTS
SENATOR WEST SO YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VENTURE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL. YOU KNOW WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED TO PUBLIC OFFICE THAT
WAS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SIX IN
THE CITY COUNCIL AND I GOT
ELECTED TO A CITY COUNCIL SEAT.
A MOST OF IT ABUTTED THE BORDER
WITH WITH THE QUANAH. AND I
REMEMBER SITTING DOWN WITH A
MEMBER. THAT- CAME INTO MY
OFFICE TO GIVE ME JUST A VERY
BRIEF SUMMARY OF ALL THE ISSUES
RELATING TO THE BORDER. AND I
REMEMBER WE WERE SCHEDULED FOR
A ONE HOUR MEETING AND WE NEED
IT SUBSTANTIALLY MORE TIME JUST
TO GO OVER. A LIST IT NOT IN
DETAIL AND I WAS REALLY BLOWN
AWAY ABOUT ALL THE ISSUES THAT
REALLY. COME TOGETHER IN A
BORDER REGION. ANYTHING THAT
YOU CAN IMAGINE AND ANYTHING
YOU CAN IMAGINE AND I REMEMBER
FEELING OVERWHELMED. THINKING
HOW DO YOU BEGIN TO ADDRESS ALL
THE CHALLENGES ALL THE PROBLEMS
AND ALL THE OPPORTUNITIES. THAT
A BORDER REGION MAKES AVAILABLE
TO THE PEOPLE OF THAT REGION.
ALL OF THESE YEARS WORKING ON
ISSUES RELATED TO THE BORDER. I
CAN ISSUE ASSURE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU. THAT NO MATTER
WHAT DISTRICT YOU SERVE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES IN YOUR DISTRICT THAT
RELATE TO SOME WAY OR ANOTHER
TO WHAT HAPPENS IN OUR STATE'S
BORDERS. AND ONE IN PARTICULAR
IS OUR OUR BORDER WITH MEXICO A
COUNTRY IN WHICH WE SHARE- SO
MUCH- IN AND FIRST OF ALL I I'D
ALSO LIKE TO. THANK OTHER
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
ASSIGNMENTS ON THIS WONDERFUL
LEVINE ALL THE WORK YOU
INVESTED IN THIS REPORT. I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING SO
THOROUGH AND- I THINK THIS
REPORT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF IN
TERMS OF THE VOLUME OF
INFORMATION THAT'S HERE'S JUST
SO WONDERFULLY WRITTEN AND WELL
DONE REPORT I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR ALL THE TIME YOU
INVESTED IN THIS BECAUSE I
THINK MEMBERS NEED THIS I THINK
THE PUBLIC NEEDS US. THIS IS A
REALLY EXCELLENT ASSESSMENT. OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE DEAL
WITH ON THE BORDER AND JUST ALL
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH AS A STATE SO. WITHOUT
REALLY GOING AND FURTHER. OF
YOU KNOW- I WANNA ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS TO REALLY READ THIS
REPORT IT'S WONDERFUL AND I I'M
I'M PLANNING TO. TO ACTUALLY
BUYING THIS AND KEEP THIS. FOR
POSTERITY SAKE- I WOULD REALLY
WANT TO THANK YOU ESPECIALLY I
FEEL YOU'RE HAVING BEEN VERY
INVESTED. IN WORKING ON ISSUES
IN MY DISTRICT AND ACROSS THE
STATE TO DEAL WITH- SOME OF
THESE ISSUES SO. THIS REALLY
MEANS A LOT TO ME PERSONALLY SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT-
SB SIX CITY FOR. A CALLS FOR
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER COMMISSION. A
SOMETHING THAT WILL HELP US TO
BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO PROBLEMS
AND BE MORE AWARE OF SOME OF
THE ISSUES AFFECTING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THIS UP OR
COMMISSION WOULD BE TASKED WITH
DEVELOPING POLICY PROPOSALS.
AND RECOMMEND RECOMMENDATIONS
TO HYPE. ON HIGH PRIORITY
ISSUES BURKE PERTAINING TO THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER
REGION. AND OTHER ISSUES
AMENDMENT MUTUAL CONCERN THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO. UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF BILL THESE
PROPOSALS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL HAVE A VENUE FOR PUBLIC
INITIAL PUBLIC DISCUSSION-
BEFORE SUBMITTAL TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR PARTS POTENTIAL FUTURE
ACTIONS IT REALLY ESTABLISHES A
FORUM. BY WHICH- KEY MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY CAN BE ENGAGE AND
BE PART OF THE PROBLEM SOLVING
PROCESS. AND USE AND PORTENT
DATA TO HELP MAKE WORK
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
ON HOW. TO BETTER POSITION OUR
STATE HOW TO PROTECT OUR STATE
HOW TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE OF
OUR COMMUNITY. BUILDING A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY BORDER
ECONOMY WILL BE VITAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
NOT ONLY FROM THE CUPBOARD
PANDEMIC BUT- JUST ANY ANY
FUTURE EVENT- YOU COULD NAME
ALMOST ANYTHING IT RELATES SO.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK. THE
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS AND STAFF AND ALL
OF YOU- FOR ALLOWING THIS
PROCESS TO CONTINUE THIS IS
VERY EXCITING FOR ME- TO. PUT
CALIFORNIA IN IN JUST A HIGHER
LEVEL AS A STATE THAT IS A
WORLD ECONOMY THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY AND OFTENTIMES WE CAN
GROW STRONGER. IF WE HAVE A
BETTER RELATIONSHIP WITH. WITH
WITH THE ENTIRE WORLD BUT
ESPECIALLY WITH OUR CLOSEST
NEIGHBOR TO THE SOUTH. SO WE
HAVE SOME WITNESS SAYS- MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU ALLOW BUCCANEER
SOMEBODY BUYS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THE INTERNATIONAL
BEST BIT BUSINESS AFFAIRS SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER- SHE'S
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DIRECTOR.
BUT WHAT THE SENATE CORRECT
REGIONAL- CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS
FARES. AND CORKAGE SILVA WHO
IS. AN IMPERIAL COLLEGE STUDENT
BODY PRESIDENT STUDENT TRUSTEE.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE MISSED
KENYA'S SOMEBODY FIVE WITH THE
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IT'S A ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE WITH US. I JUST
ON YOUR PHONE MA'AM YOU'RE ALL
SET. HELLO IN REPRESENTATION OF
CANYON COUNTRY BUT I AM SO MANY
OF HIM AND FINA'S INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS AFFAIRS COORDINATOR OF
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. AND L. ON BEHALF OF
THE CHAMBER IN SPEAKING FOR A
VARIETY OF INDUSTRIES AND SMALL
MEDIUM AND LARGE EMPLOYERS IN
OUR REGION WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY FOUR PROPOSING THE
CREATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER COMMISSION. OUR CLOSE
PROXIMITY COMPLEMENTARY
RESOURCES AND STRONG HISTORY OF
COLLABORATING WITH MEXICO HAVE
RESULTED IN A HIGH DEGREE F
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
INDEPENDENT INTERDEPENDENCE. WE
ALSO FACE A UNIQUE SET OF
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES.
HOWEVER DUE TO COVER NINETEEN
MAYBE IN MANY INDUSTRIES HAVE
BEEN HURT RESULTING IN
TREMENDOUS JOB LOSSES IN AN
ADVERSE ECONOMIC IMPACT ON OUR
REGION- ABOUT A QUARTER
COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO HOME TO A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
CENTRAL WORKERS WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK AT THE FRONT LINE. IN A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
CENTRAL WORKERS AT ALL OF THE
SUDDENLY BECAME UNEMPLOYED.
EVEN AMID FURTHER HIGHLIGHTS
LONGSTANDING INEQUITIES
INCLUDING HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
LIMITED ACCESS TO SERVICES AND
UNDER INVEST MENT IN THE REGION.
WE'RE CERTAIN THAT THE CREATION
OF A CALIFORNIA BORDER
COMMISSION WILL HELP BRIDGE THE
GAP BETWEEN OUR BORDER
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE. THE
COMMISSION WILL HELP STRENGTHEN
LOCAL INPUT TO MEXICO TO
MAXIMIZE RESOURCES ADDRESS OUR
UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND
LONGSTANDING INEQUITIES AND
SEIZE THE OPPORTUNITY THAT WILL
HELP US INCREASE OUR GLOBAL
COMPETITIVENESS. FURTHERMORE
AID PUBLIC SICKLER COMMISSION
LIKE THIS ONE WILL BE CAPABLE
OF DEVELOPING POLICY PROPOSALS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO ACHIEVE
HIS. GOALS AND AN EMPLOYEE AND
AN INFLUENTIAL FACTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MRS
ALREADY FROM- LET ME GO AHEAD
AND MOVE MODERATOR TO MR JORGE
SILVA A STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT
STUDENT TRUSTEE AT IMPERIAL
VALLEY COLLEGE MR SILVA YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ARGHA SILVA AND I WHAT
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IMPAIR ABOUT A COLLEGE
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT AFTER
ENTRUSTING. IN ADDITION I HAVE
BEEN A PERMANENT RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS I AM NOT TRANSPLANT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. ON A SOCIAL AND
CULTURAL LEVEL. CALIFORNIA
MEXICO HAVE A VERY STRONG
SHARED HISTORY. TODAY
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MORE THAN
FIFTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
RESIDENTS AMERICAN DESCENT
WEAPONS MEDIC THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO HAVE STRONG IMMEDIATE
FAMILY TIES TO MEXICO. BUT
WHERE WE CAN ADDRESS CORRECTIVE
AMERICAN DESCENT AND THEIR
NEEDS IF SB SIX EIGHT FOUR
WHICH CALL FOR THE MUCH NEEDED
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER COMMISSION PACKED WITH
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THE PROPOSAL
AND RECOMMENDATIONS HARPER
ALREADY ISSUE. PERTAINING TO
THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER
REGION AND OTHER ISSUES OF
MUTUAL CONCERN TO CALIFORNIA
AND MEXICO. I THINK EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM MOSCOW NOPE. THE
BORDER REGION OF WHAT
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT BY THE
COURT NINETEENTH ENDEMIC.
IMPACT WORK EXACERBATED
LONGSTANDING INEQUITY INCLUDING
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT LIMITED
ACCESS TO CULTURE TARGETED AND
UNDER INVESTMENT. ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION AMERICANS
WITHIN MEXICO AND MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND OF
THEM LIVE IN THE CITY JUST HOW
THE CALIFORNIA. BILL CITIES
WERE HIT HARDER BUT THE KALRA
BUYERS SPENT ALMOST ANYWHERE
ELSE IN MEXICO. DIVERT
HIGHLIGHTED BY THE NATIONAL
LEVEL BY MAY TWENTY TWENTY
ARTICLE BY THE WASHINGTON POST
WHICH CONTRIBUTE ADULT AT WORK.
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF THE VENTURE
REGIONAL WHICH QUOTED HIM
SAYING. IT'S AMAZING HOW DOES
THIS FIT PRODUCT THE BORDERS.
DON'T EXIST. IT'LL HELP PROTECT
THEM HAVE CLAIM UNDER LIKE ONE
OF MY SMALL COME HOP IN PUBLIC
BECAUSE OF. SOME OF THE POOREST
GAMES OF. WERE PART OF WITH A
MY FOOTBALL AND FAIL AND CROSS
THE BORDER WHICH YOU CAN
RETIRED. BERMAN AND I MARK OF
WORKING OR LET IN MEXICO.
ACCORDING TO PENNDOT. I THINK
NOT BECAUSE BETWEEN DATABASE IN
COLOR SHARED A WITH WITH NEXT.
WHICH REFLECT LOCAL INSTRUCT
WITH THE LACK OF RESOURCES AND
TIME RESPONSIVE TO LOCAL
IMPORT. EXPORT IF A MUCH NEEDED
BILL TO ESTABLISH UP CALIFORNIA
BORDER COMMISSION TO SEPARATE
THE PUBLIC THE COLDER BODY ON
CULTURAL ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES WE'VE BEEN
TO CALIFORNIA BORDER REGION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME YEAH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WERE YOU ABLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR SILVA
LET ME NOW ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. C. NINE US
SERGEANT IS THERE ANY IN THE
ROOM TEST. STATION SENAD MISTER
MODERATOR IS OR ANYONE ELSE ON
THE CONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS
GOING TO GO AHEAD GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE IN THE
PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE.
IN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
EIGHT FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND MADAM
CHAIR I NOBODY IS KILLING UP.
LET US NOW HERE FROM ALL THE
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. C. NINE SERGEANT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
LET ME MOVE TO MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE IN
THE CONFERENCE LINE THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AGAIN
JUST TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I'M SURE
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. MEMBERS
IT IS NOW I TIME FOR DISCUSSION
DO ANY MEMBERS WISH TO SPEAK
AND ASK QUESTIONS OF SENATOR
WEST SO I HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OPERATOR FOR BATH THANK YOU IS
NOT SO MUCH A QUESTION OF THE-
COMMENT OF GRATITUDE. TO THE
CENTER FOR BRING THIS FORWARD.
I USED TO SERVE ON THE BORDERS
COMMITTEE- FOR SANDAG AND- IT
YOU KNOW FROM BEING FROM NORTH
COUNTY SAN DIEGO WE DON'T
ALWAYS GET DOWN TO THE BORDER.
ON A REGULAR BASIS. AND IT IS.
YOU KNOW SURPRISING AND
IMPRESSIVE HOW INTEGRATED OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE WHAT WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT OF THE GOING
ACROSS THE BORDER EVERY DAY. IS
A REALITY AND IT DRIVES OUR
ECONOMY AND SAN DIEGO SO. WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRING THIS WE'RE GOING TO BE
HAPPY TO BE ADDED. AS A CO
AUTHOR AT THE NEXT AVAILABLE
TIME IN THE BUILDING I DID.
WHEN I REMOVE THE BILL RIGHT
YES SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION OF
OUR BOERNER HORVATH AND WE HAVE
A SECOND BY A RAMOS. SENATE
ALSO DO YOU WISH TO PROVIDE
CLOSING STATEMENTS. I JUST
SIMPLY THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IT I- ALSO SHOP AROUND
FOR CO AUTHORS OF ANYBODY. BUT
ANYWAY I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
MEMBERS AS I MENTIONED THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION ON SB SIX EIGHT FOUR IS
DUE PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION.
WELL THE CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YOUR
CERVANTES I HEAR CERVANTES HI
VICE YOU'RE CUNNINGHAM. I'M A
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH SOME OF
BOERNER HORVATH HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAD. FILEM RICH OUT HI
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS SEVERAL MOST HI ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH. FULLER SMITH I.
WE WILL PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL
SO WE CAN HAVE MEMBERS ADDED ON
AND MEMBERS WE WILL LIFT THE
CAR AFTER THE END OF THE NEXT
PRESENTATION TO GIVE SERGEANTS
A CHANCE TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. I TODAY WE ARE HEARING
THAT. THEIR NEXT BILL ON THE
AGENDA SB EIGHT AWAIT BY
SENATOR ROTH RELATING TO THE
MADE IN CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. I
BEFORE THE OFFER DOES BEGAN HIS
BILL PRESENTATION LET ME GIVE
EVERYONE NOTICED THAT THE PHONE
LINES ARE NOW OPEN. FOR
WITNESSES TO GET IN THE QUEUE
THAT NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. AT SENATOR WALK
ROCK WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED IN COMMON
EIGHT. OF THE BILL ANALYSIS AS
ITEMS AB AND ITEMS C. AS TO
ITEM BE RELATING TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL ENFORCEMENT I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO. TAKE SOME ADDITIONAL TIME
TO REVIEW THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSALS- CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVES AND GET BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AUGUST FIRST.
THAT'S CORRECT THE MANAGER
MEMBERS WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS A AND C. AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THE DETAILS OUTLINED IN YOUR
AMENDMENT BE RELATIVE TO THE-
PARTICIPATION OF PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS- IN THIS A PROCESS
WITH REGARD TO THE ENFORCEMENT.
AS YOU KNOW THIS BILL RE
LAUNCHES THE MADE IN CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM TO LEVERAGE
CALIFORNIA'S BRAND. TO PROMOTE
OUR CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
EMPLOYEES. AND PRODUCTS AN
ESTIMATED 93% OF CALIFORNIA'S
MANUFACTURERS ARE SMALL
BUSINESS. DESPITE THE SIZE IN
THE ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTIONS OF
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES THE
STATE'S LABELING PROGRAM. TO
PROMOTE THIS MANUFACTURING
SECTOR IS HIGHLY UNDER
UTILIZED. AND INACCESSIBLE.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL CHANGES HOPEFULLY
WILL INCREASE PARTICIPATION IN
THE MADE IN CALIFORNIA PROGRAM
AND PROMOTE MANUFACTURING. IN
THIS STATE. THE BILL AS
PROPOSED WOULD REMOVE THE MADE
IN USA STANDARD AND THE THIRD
PARTY CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS IN THE CURRENT
PROGRAM. ALIGNING THE PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS WITH MADE IN
PROGRAMS IN OTHER STATES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. AS CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS ECONOMIC RECOVERY POST
COVERT NINETEEN. THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT SMALL
AND MEDIUM SIZED MANUFACTURERS
IN THE STATE BY PROMOTING
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA MADE
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA BASED
MANUFACTURERS. I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
MARAL FARSI DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION. AT AFFAIRS FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
DEAN TALLEY POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. AND
WITH THAT MAN I'M SURE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL ADOPT
THESE AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE SEE I DO SEE
MORE ALL PHARMACY IT WITH US
TODAY IN THE HEARING ROOM I
PLEASE COME FORWARD. BY WHEN
YOU ARE READY AND YOU CAN BE
GET. SO THEY CATCH THIS. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MORRELL FIRSTHAND THE
LEGISLATIVE DEPUTY FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT- WE
HAVE HAVE BEEN VERY PROUD OF
THIS PROGRAM IT'S BEEN AROUND
FOR ABOUT- SEVEN EIGHT YEARS
AND WE BEAT WE CAN IMPLEMENTING
IT ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO- TO AND
WE EXPERIENCE JUST SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN GETTING- SMALL
BUSINESSES TO APPLY AND SUPPORT
THE LABEL I GUESS THE WAY THAT
WE WOULD DESCRIBE IT IS IT'S A
WAY TO SHOW PRIDE- IN OUR STATE
IT'S A WAY TO DRIVE HOME THE
POINT THAT- THINGS ARE MADE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY CAN'T BE
MADE IN CALIFORNIA- AND WE'VE
DONE MULTIPLE SURVEYS. AND
RECEIVE A DONE SEVERAL FOCUS
GROUPS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
CHALLENGES ARE WOULD BE IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS AND WHY FOLKS
ARE PARTICIPATING AND- AND WHAT
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED IS THE-
MEETING USA STANDARD IS A VERY
VERY HIGH THRESHOLD NOT THAT
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE BUT IT'S A HIGH
THRESHOLD AND ALSO THAT- SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE CHALLENGES
FINDING A THIRD PARTY CERTIFIED
CERTIFIER AND THAT IS A COSTS
CONDUCIVE THAT- THAT WOULD
APPROVE THAT THEIR PRODUCTS
COULD PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM AND MEET ALL THE MARKS
SO- HERE WE ARE TODAY WE ARE
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO SENATOR
ROTH FOR- CHAMPIONING THIS BILL
CHAMPIONING SMALL BUSINESSES-
AS YOU DO MADAM CHAIR- YOU KNOW
I WOULD HAVE. IMPORTANT REGION
A THE INLAND EMPIRE IS FOR
MANUFACTURING AND SMALL
BUSINESSES AND SO- THESE
CHANGES THAT WE BELIEVE WOULD
BE A SUPPORTIVE OF INCREASING
THE PARTICIPATION WHAT WE DO
PLAN TO DO IS LAUNCH THE
PROGRAM WITH AN ADDITIONAL
PROMOTION OPPORTUNITIES WHEN A
BUSINESSES APPLY AND RECEIVE
THE MEETING CALIFORNIA LABEL WE
WILL PROMOTE THEM THROUGH OUR
OWN NETWORKS- WE OFFER THEM
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EXPOSURE- TO ELEVATE WHAT THAT
MEETING CALIFORNIA BRAND IS AND
SO WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF THAT
AT THAT LABEL IN THE AND ARE
EIGHT. SO I WILL THEIR- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS TODAY
DIRECTOR FARSI I DO UNDERSTAND
WE LSO HAVE MISTER DEAN TALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WITH US TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- SCREWED UP TO BE WITH
YOU HERE TODAY MY NAME IS DEAN
TALLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION- HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT AWAIT- SEMG
A WE REPRESENT OVER FOUR
HUNDRED BUSINESSES. THAT
REPRESENT THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM
OF MANUFACTURING SO LARGE
MEDIUM SMALL GENERATING ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
EMPLOYING ABOUT ONE POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. NOW OF
COURSE THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS HAD A MASSIVE
IMPACT ON MANUFACTURERS AND
BUSINESSES. THE ANALYSIS
REFERENCES IN GREAT IN GREAT
DETAIL SO I WANT SPERRY WITH
THAT BUT- AROUND A- HUNDRED
THOUSANDS OF DIFFERENT
BUSINESSES MANUFACTURERS IN THE
LOST- WITH THE TIMING OF COMING
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC WE WILL
HAVE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES IN THE
NEXT YEAR. SO BY SUPPORTING
THIS BILL WE WISH TO PROMOTE
CALIFORNIA MADE IS A GREAT
INCENTIVE AND A TOOL. TOWARD
INCREASING OUR MANUFACTURING
WORKFORCE AND BETTERING THIS
ECONOMY. SB EIGHT OH EIGHT IS
ONE OF OUR MAKER BILLS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO BE AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THIS PROCESS. WE HAVE
TO GET THIS BILL OFF THE GROUND
BY WORKING TOGETHER AS WELL
REPRESENTED TODAY I JUST WANT
TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO THE
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MADAM CHAIR-
AND OF COURSE THE GOOD SENATOR
BRING THIS FOURTH I WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EVERYONE. AND GETTING THIS
MOVING FORWARD RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER TALLY LET IT LET ME
NOW ASK THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL.
THE SERGEANTS IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SENAD MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE IN
THE CONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF- SB EIGHT
OH EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE FILED BY ZERO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT. AND WE DO NOT WANT TO
END UP ONE MOMENT ARE WE GIVEN
THEIR LINE NUMBER.
THANKS ONE
MOMENT THE OPERATOR SHOULD HAVE
THEIR LINE NUMBER GIVEN THAT
MUCH DATA QUESTION ONE I'M SO
SORRY ONE SECOND PLEASE.
EVERYBODY ELSE GOING AT ONE
ZERO. TO QUEUE UP. ONE ZERO.
AND WE WILL BEGIN. WITH ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIRTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE STEVENS I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR
CALIPERS SHORT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL BECAUSE IT
CREATES OPPORTUNITY FOR
MANUFACTURING. GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IMPACTS OF
MANUFACTURING WE ARE HAPPY THAT
THE BILL MAKES THE MEETING
CALIFORNIA DESIGNATION MORE
ATTAINABLE. THANK YOU. AND A
FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB EIGHT AWAIT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND MADAM
CHAIR NOBODY'S GIVING UP. AT
THIS TIME LET ME BEGIN IT WITH
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. C. NINE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. LET ME MOVE TO
MISTER MODERATOR I WAS THERE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE CONFERENCE
LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THE MANAGER AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB EIGHT
OH EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. AND NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
MADAM CHAIR. IT IS TIME FOR
DISCUSSION DURING THE MEMBERS
WISH TO ASK QUESTIONS OF
SENATOR ROTH OR ANY WITNESSES
TODAY I SEE THAT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. IS ONE
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD SENATOR ROTH LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE US OF A THINGS ARE MADE IN
THE US OF A PEOPLE LIKE THAT
THE WORLD BUT NOW WE CAN
QUALIFY THAT THEIR MAIDEN
CALIFORNIA. WHICH WILL BRING
BACK OUR MANUFACTURING I HOPE
WITH A BIG BOOM IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS AND IT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A CO AUTHOR WHEN
IT'S TIME I'D LOVE TO BE AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. AND I
LIKE TO ECHO THAT SAYS SENATOR
ROCK THANK YOU FOR CHAMPION. HI
THIS BILL AND THE POSITIVE
IMPACT IT WILL HAVE BEEN THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE. ON SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS AS IT RELATES TO-
YOUR- YOUR BILL EIGHT OH EIGHT.
LET ME. GO AHEAD AND ALSO CALL
ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND AT THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
QUESTION ABOUT PROGRAMS IN
OTHER STATES AS OFFICE LOOKED
AT WHAT OTHER STATES DO
ATTITUDE TO VERIFY IN STATE
MANUFACTURING YEP. ARE THERE
COMPLIANCE IS THEIR APARTMENT
ARE THERE PENALTIES AFTER GETS
PICKED UP THAT WOULD BE. YUSOF
IT DEPENDS ON THE STATE SOME
STATES FOR EXAMPLE IF THEY FIND
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH
THE- THEY HAVE A CERTIFICATION
WITH THE PROBLEM OF THE SELF
CERTIFICATION THEY SIMPLY A
PRIVATE THE COMPANY FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
OTHER STATES- TREATED AS A
MISDEMEANOR IT DEPENDS ON THE
STATE AND FRANKLY- YOU KNOW THE
PROGRAM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS
INTENDED TO BE A POSITIVE
PROGRAM A RATHER THAN A
NEGATIVE ONE AND SO WE HAVE TO
SORT OF THREAD THE NEEDLE WHEN
IT COMES TO. ENFORCEMENT AND TO
TRY TO MAKE IT UP CONTINUE TO
MAKE IT  POSITIVE PROGRAM TO
TRY TO ENCOURAGE BUSINESSES TO
PARTICIPATE AND FOR THAT REASON
THAT'S WHY I'LL BE WORKING WITH
THE YOUR CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF TO TRY TO
REFINE THE ENFORCEMENT PIECE SO
WE GET THAT RIGHT THE RIGHT
BALANCE OF WEEK CONTINUE TO GO
FORWARD WITH A POSITIVE PROGRAM
NOT A NEGATIVE ONE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
FOLKS THAT ARE SELF CERTIFYING
THAT 51% OR GREATER IN FACT OUR
MANUFACTURING WITH GREATER THAN
A 51% OR MORE. OF PARTS AND
SUPPLIES FROM CALIFORNIA THAT
IF YOU'RE GETTING YES AND AT
AND I THINK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FOCUSING ON THREADING THAT
NEEDLE- AND ENSURING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE INADVERTENTLY CREATE
SORT OF A FEDERAL THAT THEN.
YEAH IT TAKES AWAY FROM SOME OF
THE POSITIVITY OF THE PROGRAM
ITSELF STEP THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING. TO ASK QUESTIONS LET
ME GO AHEAD AND STATE THAT WE
DO HAVE A MOTION- BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH IN THE SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS SENATOR
ROCK DO YOU WISH TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING STATEMENTS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF RESPECT AS
FROM ABOUT. THE MOTION ON SB IT
AWAY IS DUE PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
THE PREPARATIONS WILL BE CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL ROLE. SB
EIGHT AWAIT TWO PASSES AMENDED
TO AND RIVER FOR ALL TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR CERVANTES HIGH CHAIR
CERVANTES FIVE VICE CHAIR
CUNNINGHAM. BUT YOU'RE
CUNNINGHAM AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAVA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHILD I REMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
FULLER PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS. SYLMAR RAMOS I
STILL REMEMBER SPENT. SUMMER
SMITH HI. AND ON A VOTE OF
SEVEN TO ZERO S. B. IT AWAY IS
OUT. THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR OFF.
MEMBERS AT LET ME GO AHEAD AND
OPEN AND LET THE CALL. ON OUR
FIRST ITEM S. B. SIX EIGHT
FOUR. SENATOR WAS SO CALIFORNIA
BORDER COMMISSION WHICH IS TO
PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRG CONSULTANT
CAN PLEASE CALL ROLE FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SO THIS IS SB
SIX EIGHT FORTY PASSES AMENDED
SHOULD RIVER FOR ALL TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
VICE CHAIR CUNNINGHAM. I THINK
YOU'RE CUNNINGHAM I REMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. SERVER
PETRIE-NORRIS HI. THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO. MEMBERS
THAT THIS CONCLUDES THE WORK OF
THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE WE
ARE TURNED.